at 40 Yahoo Sports national college
football and basketball columnist got a
busy day today
in fact Pat let the audience know where
you are right now dan this is like a cop
movie
I am staked out outside the University
of Louisville administration building
got it donut got a diet you know waiting
for somebody to get fired
is there media around there and do you
expect a firing today well there
definitely is media here there's a
couple satellite trucks there's a radio
station there's a newspaper reporter a
photographer and I expect something to
happen today yes I do I mean I think
that this is this scandal is enough the
cumulative effect of what although
everything that's happened in Louisville
basketball is enough that they need to
make a very quick action here the
problem of course is it they have an
interim president and if you're gonna
take out Pitino and Thom Jurek I mean
the leadership vacuum is immense at this
point do they let Pitino resign or is he
fired if that's how this plays out it's
a good question I'm not sure what the
the you know the technical terms maybe
but I I absolutely think that it would
be the university wanting him to leave
and him probably seeing the handwriting
on the wall the squabbling it from all
indications may come about how big the
buyout is I don't think there's gonna be
much of a fight about whether or not you
would stay as coach wait so there's
going to be a buyout I think that that's
possible I know that Terry minors radio
personality in town who's a very good
friend of Patino's had a blog post today
saying that there could be a
bare-knuckle fight over a over the
buyout
how did we get to this point with Pitino
with this recruit given the fact that he
had these comments about this recruit
where he said in my 40 years it's
basically the luckiest recruit I've ever
gotten and he fell into my lap and then
all of a sudden fell into his lap and
the guy ended up getting up and had
$100,000 in his pocket did I go there no
it's no it's you know
everything that went on with this
recruit I thought there were plenty of
red flags you've got this undeclared
five star guy who's you know kind of
ping-ponging around I want to go here I
want to go there I want to go here it's
June he still hasn't made a declaration
all of a sudden he's going to a
Louisville where he really haven't been
seriously involved in a long time if
you're if you don't have red flags going
off then what the heck you paying
attention to I wonder if is there a way
that Louisville has uses Rick as the
sacrificial lamb to avoid the death
penalty
I I don't know if we have the death
penalty anymore but is that one of those
that that the egg we're gonna fire him
and fire our ad to avoid really really
strong sanctions yeah I mean that might
I think that would be their only defense
against the death penalty quite frankly
I mean I wrote yesterday I think they
should get the death penalty because the
repeat violator statute which is what
the death penalty is based on what it
was used with SMU is if you are
committing major violations when you're
already on probation for other major
violations and this is that to a tee I
mean they were buying one player
involved with adidas buying a player for
a hundred thousand a week or so before
they got sanctions then they were
involved in an agreement or a discussion
of paying two hundred and fifty thousand
to another player like six weeks after
they had been sanctioned I mean it is
brazen and egregious for immensitively
rule standpoint how deep how wide do you
think this gets though very deep very
wide they're they're more terrified
basketball coaches in America to
yesterday and today then there probably
have ever been at one time because the
feds are involved we haven't even gotten
to the point of people to rolling over
on each other and I think everybody
understands this has been a tacit way of
doing business for quite a while in
college basketball if you're recruiting
top guys so everybody who's signing top
50 players guess what
you better be you better have good
explanations for how it all came to be
and be ready for the FBI to come in and
start asking questions could this lead
to changes in amateurism and paying
players and one-and-done
I mean only and it's not just basketball
that this happens people
should understand that but basketball is
under the microscope right now but what
do you think about amateurism and paying
players as a result of this yeah I mean
I yeah I think that is reinvigorates
that discussion and it should you know
that to me I think there's an easier
solution it is you're right it is not
just a basketball issue it absolutely
goes on in football as well but I think
there's an easier solution to the
basketball situation get rid of the
one-and-done or the rule that you got to
be 19 to turn pro and these guys the
vast majority of them they're getting
paid in these situations and getting
agents coming into college our guys that
are gonna go pro in a year or maybe two
so let them go pro immediately out of
high school reinstate that and take this
corrupt underground economy out of it or
as you said and you alluded to you know
go back to the the much bigger picture
and let's rethink the whole amateurism
model if you can ask Pitino one question
today what would it be I you know I
think I would ask him why and I've known
him a long long time I've known him well
I've got had a great relationship with
him and it certainly wasn't fun to write
a column saying he needs to be fired and
I think I would say Rick you guys have
are doing well everything is going well
why would you why would you get involved
in this situation why would you have
assistant coaches involved in this you
don't need it you're tarnishing a great
legacy by even being involved in these
sort of situations and I understand it's
kind of how business gets done and he's
a competitive man but think of the
damage that can be done when this is
something like this comes to light and
what has been done and will be done to
his legacy what if he just says I didn't
know anything about this can he say that
again good enough no you can't say it
again you get one I didn't know card in
your career some guys don't even get
that he played that and some people
thought he shouldn't have been able to
play it last time you can't play that I
didn't know card twice have fun today
Pat great to talk to you thank you Dan
that's Pat 40 yahoo sports national
college football basketball columnist
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you